women are like pathetic or need a man or
xyz it's like no baby back yourself yeah
we do need men though we do we don't
need them because they do no because
they're lesbians who do you who do you
call to get your car fixed a man or a
woman your toilet breaks down who do you
call so i i fix my own car i can i can
do it i'm most mechanics your power your
power supply who runs it who runs the
infrastructure of society men or women
oh at the moment obviously yeah
because because patriarchy
wait do i need a man no this is i'm
obsessed with being a woman in a
male-dominated industry i do all of my
own carpentry
right but regardless of that like you
agree that men run the infrastructure so
therefore at the moment yeah men run the
world so they we need men
yeah yeah on a wider scale yes a wider
scale on a personal scale no because you
don't need a man to provide for you
right you can earn all right wait but we
need men to run the industries that keep
us alive and well not necessarily no so
because i know female mechanics
engineers right
remember remember that's exception like
those industries are like 99 percent now
yeah but for now right so now do you and
we can change that we can't what do we
do but do we want to change that some
women do something
how do you know the difference between
women picking the industries they want
to pick
and
trying to [ __ ] the patriarchy no no i'm
saying like like
how do you know the difference between
women picking the industries they want
to pick
so like i don't know a lot of girls that
want to be plumbers mechanics engineers
and all that stuff
right but you're the exception you're
not the rule i don't know how many
that's what i'm saying so so when you
say things like it's because i'm so
valid but you're still valid but i'm
saying when you say things like because
of the patriarchy that's why women are
in those fields how do you know it's the
patriarchy and not women choosing what
they want to choose well you don't and
that's not my business right not my
business i know but like why do you
automatically assume patriarchy i don't
know automatically assume it but that's
why we need men because of the
patriarchy right because they are the
ones who at the moment control most of
the world that's what we need how do you
know women don't control most of the
world because they don't pick the
industries where they're like in control
it's not michael white it's right that's
like gray area interaction right right
but i'm saying like could it possibly
just be like i don't think there's
anything stopping women from getting a
job today i don't think we have anything
i think it's easier for women than men
yeah like and then yeah that's again it
depends what industry it depends what
like i think this whole like the concept
of sleeping away to the top
women will get small hairs okay
oh yeah yeah
but
but then it's like oh she was and it's
like well actually we're not then saying
you didn't respect a woman's capability
qualifications and you know you actually
disrespected her and were like you're
only valuable for your sexual like well
i think i think it's because like women
do that
but yeah yeah right and they get and
like me and like women i don't think
kamala would be in the position that
she's in if she didn't
do it yeah yeah but then it's like
people who have issues and it breaks
back to body count it's like i feel very
powerful when i sleep with a lot of men
i feel very powerful because i'm like
i i feel like i've like frauded half of
them i'm like you think that i'm good i
was like i'm i'm nothing compared to
half these [ __ ] out here like i'm
um
but
then like only fans as well it's a real
dichotomous like people being like is it
female empowerment to make money off of
your body or is it disrespectful is it
and i'm very much a a middle ground
honestly
i'm looking at people like choosing what
they want to choose but i just think
we're not honest with women about the
consequences so like even with body
cameras
who cares because i don't care about the
consequences
i would have a porno and be like people
like do you care if your family yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] about my
that's totally fine like i'm all for
empowering women to do what i want to do
like if you if you want to go start your
only fans go ahead i'm not going to stop
you
go crazy like get that back but but
what i do think we do is like lie to
younger women and tell them there's no
consequences for that stuff
and and so we'll say like oh do sleep
with whoever you want and men won't care
they shouldn't care but they do care but
uh it depends if you think it's a lie it
really it's really like it's not it's
not it's not if i think it's a lie it's
like i have these
99 male followers i listen to men talk
every day they do care and biologically
there's a reason they care yeah i mean i
do do they care less than they did 100
years ago sure sure yeah yeah i don't
think like most guys want to but then
i think most guys don't want their [ __ ]
on only fans yeah but then we can talk
about okay like let's get real like
women couldn't vote women couldn't have
jobs right black people were seen as
literally inhumane right and so you know
if we took that
that mindset back to where we were then
black people weren't human mm-hmm and so
you would not be sat here with us
because you would not yeah you would not
yet i'm just a little confused what is
that like i just was
i'm just confused what did that have to
do with what we were talking about so
it's information to saying like we're
lying okay so then essentially the
people who went black people are people
they were liars back then okay i don't
know but this is this is what i'm saying
it's it's lying to women when we're
saying like statistically they're like
for example when you when you sleep with
more men you lose your ability to pair
bond so you have a harder time bonding
with your husband later on like the
person that you marry and there there's
a million studies that will back this up
yeah the people you sleep with the
less
like you you have a higher probability
of being divorced yeah yeah so so saying
to women empower yourself and sleep with
whoever you i'm not i'm not saying women
should be prudent not everyone wants to
get married and not everyone wants to be
parabonded not everyone and not everyone
is scared
no and that's that's fine and so but i
think we should give women all of the
information oh yeah so yeah so i'm
saying like if you don't want to be
married and you want to be like by
yourself if that's what you want to do
go ahead go go do it i'm don't but like
don't
i think a lot of times girls follow this
advice and they're not they're not
giving all the information but we're
also just assuming that every man is
going to be like
you're worthless oh i'm not i'm not
assuming every man but i think the like
majority okay
would you would you prefer a girl that
has slept with a hundred people or slept
with ten
especially for me ten yeah yeah and like
i think if you ask like yeah guys would
you prefer someone more pure or more
more of a hoe most guys are going to say
more pure yeah but then you see for a
relationship yeah but then you see who
and what people then you see who and
what people watch on social media or
porn or who they engage with and you're
like oh you're a hot celebrity or
someone with a lot of followers or
someone who is very desirable or someone
who is and that's it nothing is black
and white the one thing i say about that
is i i understand about the whole
desirable thing but guys don't really
care
how much
a girl is desired by other men that
seems to be more of a
woman thing that they'll use
pre-selected by other women does that
make sense so like you know you said
this example i'll be honest no matter
how many guys are looking and thirsting
over lizzo
i'm not going to be thirsting over her i
mean she's not what i would look for
whereas like you get someone like jonah
hill if he was just your average guy no
one would want him but because of who he
is and women fawn over him a lot of them
see him as attractive because he's
desirable to other women does that make
sense
yeah like 100 like i'm that's it i'm
unfortunately i i'm aware of the reality
i'm not like delusional
um
but then i'm aware of the science but so
being that's it psychology has been my
life for the past like oh my god when i
started i started studying it
oh my god 12 years ago
um and so it's the understanding of why
its behavior has come become that way
and the anthropology and all of that
stuff
um so i come from more of a scientific
fact but then i'm like i obviously know
my bias i obviously know xyz but yeah
like i'm not gonna i'm not delusional in
the lizzo being a big woman is not
attractive but then you know like yeah
it's so so would you agree that we
should give like like the advice if a
for a girl that wants to be married
would be to like sleep with as little
men as possible
if you want to get married to the
highest value guy you can
hmm no i'm not saying like be a prude
i'm not saying no no no yeah it's like
it's like you should want to marry a man
that wants you regardless but but you
don't think you don't think your choices
have consequences like no i think
there's a consequence right and so you
don't think we should be honest to the
next generation saying hey these are the
consequences for those actions if you if
you get on the internet and you you post
your naked body like a guy that that's
worth a
day guy will care and one guy won't but
but
do the guys you want care is the
question that's i think that's different
i think the the difference is the the
high quality guys that most other women
would want
he's more he's gonna care about these
things whereas there'll be some guys who
don't care but it's likely that those
guys that don't care not the guys you
want but then quality again is
subjective like would you rather have
someone who just accepts you for who you
are and loves you for who you are and
your history because then porn stars get
married but the numbers porn stars okay
but here's the thing they need to other
porn stars though
but but here's statistically actually
not correct because i get studied here's
here's the thing the numbers the numbers
don't lie and actions have consequences
right and so we could say oh it's
subjective like what is quality but like
when you it's supply and demand yeah
like what what kind of then why do we
need to all fit into the majority why do
we like i'm very happy being an anomaly
i'm very happy being oh oh like and i
and i say and i say go if you want to be
an anomaly go do it if that's what makes
you happy i'm i'm never going to tell
someone how to live their life but what
i'm saying is like why do we lie to
younger women instead of giving them all
the information
like why don't we say the younger woman
if you if you want the highest the guy
with the most options okay if you want
the highest quality guy you can attain
putting your starting and only fans is
not the best way to get there but then
it's like i don't understand like to me
like this is common sense and i feel
like we should agree on this and it's
almost like you like are looking for
that exception because you don't want to
like
you don't want to because what we're
doing then is putting what he wants and
he desires and he values above ourselves
well because it's not always about you
and that's what i'm saying is that he
gets to choose who he wants to marry and
if you want to we get to choose who we
want to marry
women marry who they can no i don't
that's that's true like women
they have to propose so we don't choose
we don't have to no not at all
but do you not think do you not think
would you agree that women decide who
have sex
yeah yeah
so we do not think that it is men who
decide who gets married
because a woman can say no
or a woman can ask and a woman has the
ability to be like look if you're not
going to commit to me i'm going to walk
away no i know but men can also say no
to sex right but we understand that
culturally when it comes to having sex
it is women who decide get access
yeah but you women usually don't say no
to marriage either
the majority of women who you're
proposed to accept
i don't yeah i don't know statistically
that was it and again it's because what
i mean is like you know you know that
when you stay from the first day of a
guy you know that he would have sex with
you straight away
so
nine times out of ten a guy is raised to
have sex before the woman that's why she
has the power to who has sex right
but also nine times out of ten it is the
woman who is ready for the commitment so
he decides who he commits to and i think
that's what pearl's saying saying that
when it comes to marriage i i think
here's the thing like
before any woman has sex with a guy
she has he has to qualify himself to her
before she accepts that intimacy right
so the same is true
that women have to qualify themselves to
men if they want relationship and
commitment
but then so this then falls back to the
patriarchy why is it that women
are the ones who are like i have to look
good i have to be hairless well why do
the men have to say oh i have to have a
good job i have to like a girl could be
unemployed a dude will still date her
but like men have to qualify themselves
to women too it's like like you're
trying to like take away the things that
men care about yeah and the things that
like the things that women and men care
about just are yeah well that's that's
why i'm very i'm so frustrating and that
i'm very gray area i'm very so that's it
i've had men that are broke men that uh
object i'm gonna say objectively not
very good looking men that are short men
that actually bring little to the table
other than being nice right and um but
would you would you prefer a man that
like i would prefer yeah i would 100
percent prefer a man that brought me
more offered me more but it didn't stop
me from dating other men it didn't stop
me right but then i think
i think i'm the anomaly in that but i'm
saying like you would still prefer the
man that had more just like the man
would still prefer the woman that had
had less guys yeah and i think like like
it just is i'm not saying i mean i mean
it's not like you know
like double standards just are yeah yeah
i was gonna say as well do you not um
i think the difference is
that and this goes back to like what you
were saying earlier what we've all said
earlier is i understand the notion of
you know you said oh but you should want
someone who loves you for you
but we all acknowledged earlier earlier
that love isn't condition is not
unconditional like love is very or if we
say love at least who we choose is
definitely conditional and some like you
could meet a guy who you think oh he
rocks my world intimacy wise but if you
want to start having a family and he's
really not doing anything with his life
it's like you may really care about him
but you may not choose him over the next
guy who can do that for you does that
make sense yeah and then i think it also
depends upon like i'm gonna be real it
really depends upon your mental health
your well-being you're like so i settled
for people who treat me like [ __ ]
and if if someone outside when amy this
is what this guy is doing to me i'd be
like are you confused like leave him
like what the [ __ ]
um
and yeah like i fully like agree with
that i fully agree that like that's it's
just not a simple yes or no but would
you would you would you then go back
because love is conditional would you go
back on your statement that like the man
shouldn't love you for you like it's
it's conditional based on the choices
yeah like that's it so yeah that makes
sense so so you would agree then to
younger women we should tell you them
that actions have consequences and going
on only fans might not be the best
action if you want a husband i think
well that's the reality is that yeah it
will it will have consequences yeah
because it will some men won't care some
men will care right you have to be okay
and you have to be responsible to be
like i know that if i'm one only fans
some men are going to be like you're
trash long as you're okay with that then
and especially the men you want just
like like women that are models who do
they tend to date
oh hot models yeah yeah no no like like
rich men yeah rich men
men with the option i mean look at i'm
not saying like all guys that's like the
halo effect as well like if you are good
looking you are deemed to be more worthy
well then like a bad looking person no
it's more for women like men it's more
their accomplishments like us we have a
lot more value in our looks
which we all we enjoy the benefits of
but that's well wow oh and this is such
an anti like feminist thing but
i will sometimes i will i'm
i'm a feminist but
in this world i'm like if i can back my
eyelashes and do the whole little cute
little oh i'm like no i will fully milk
yeah i'm going to try sure i will do it
and people like but you're a feminist
and you shouldn't do that and i'm like
look if i need to get ahead anyway i can
if i need to
be better looking yeah to
come across as better like i'm going to
be real well if i came here looking like
trash i think that i'd get a lot like
more mean
comments like i'm gonna i'm gonna be
real um
and yeah like no i totally like well
yeah i think it's like we so it's almost
like like feminism they want equality
when it
it they almost only want it to gray no
no i'm saying like we don't actually
want equality it's just equality when it
benefits us yeah so so here's the thing
because i think you're right if you're
going to call a spade a spade you you as
a woman you're going to use
the advantages you have
of being a woman to get yourself ahead
right that's what you just said
[Music]
so then
can we i'm just playing devil's advocate
here can we then get annoyed at men
who use the advantages that they have to
get ahead
yeah but oh that's it it's it's not all
like it depends on the situation the
circumstance i'm so frustrating that i'm
very much like every situation
you can't blacklight i think it's just
when you have to answer a question that
goes against your belief system that's
what that's no but that's no so because
i did dbt i'm non-judgmental and i'm
very much non
you don't commit you sit on the fence
because nothing is black and white
nothing and it makes life a lot more
enjoyable to not be so
committed to a certain belief or a
certain way of thinking i'm very
open-minded i'm very i'm very happy to
be told
i'm very happy for someone to have a
different opinion and to argue it and
i'm very much like oh do you know what
i've changed so i used to be very
anti-abortion this is what really
surprises people i was very
anti-abortion as a teenager right and
then i switched and i was very i was
actually i was a massive prude i was a
massive prude i was very judgmental on
girls who were promiscuous or xyz
and now i'm like the opposite
and i'm very open to it it's not really
like it's not really like judgmental i i
don't
i don't care what people do like i don't
i don't think who you sleep with says
who you are as a person like i don't
know i don't give it like you want to do
that but i just what i don't like is
acting like there's no consequences for
it no there are and there is i'm telling
young girls there's no consequences
because there are and that would
literally be a
a blank face lie because we know they're
right we know they're all right and in
an ideal world
yeah there wouldn't be but you've got to
be you've got to be a realist you've got
to be a realist and be like there are
consequences to certain men and if those
are the men that you're after then you
have to actually cater to what they want
right and right so yeah yeah yeah so we
agree yeah yeah in a realist way yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no
yeah like next question no no